All right Michael, last example
I want to give you is something
that comes from the world of
what's called drama management.
And the way I'm going to
introduce this to you
is I'm going to point out what we've
actually been talking about so far.
So I'm cheating a little bit for
you in helping you with what have
we learned part of the lesson.
So I'm going to claim
that if you think about
at least the last few things
about communication and
coaching particularly on the coaching
thing with human beings we've kind of
talked about three different ways that
a human can communicate to an agent.
The first is demonstrations.
You show the example of one
particular drawing through
a grid world to do inverse reinforcement
learning and that was a demonstration.
And I can give you
multiple demonstrations.
And we talked a little bit about rewards
and that what a human can give you is
rewards for various things that you do
and that's a kind of reward shaping way.
And then last thing we talked
about was policy shaping where
the human is communicating to
you is not demonstrations and
not reward values, but
actually telling you
what the correct policy thing is in
response to things that you've done.
And the last policies is different from
the first demonstrations in that in
the first case you would actually
demonstrate what the right action is.
But here with the policy shaping
you're just giving critique that
gives information about whether
a particular policy is correct or not.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, that's interesting there's
these different kind of mechanisms for
giving feedback.
>> Right, so I want to talk
about another sort of model and
way of doing coordination.
This time between a human and
an agent who's interacting
with another human, right?
So in the cases we described
before there were two.
There was the human and
there was an agent, but
here I'm going to say
there's a third person.
So I'm going to replace the human
with what I'm going to call a Player.
For example,
a player of a game like Pac-Man.
The Agent,
which in this case would be Pac-Man, and
a third human,
I'm going to call the Author.
So in the world of drama managment
there's this basic idea that
there are these things like Choose
Your Own Adventure stories there's
ways of seeing tasks in the world
as if they are a games.
Where there's some Author, someone who
designs the game designs the system
whether it be Pac-Man or
a story or a movie or
anything if you can imagine any sort
of interaction in the world and
wants to build an Agent,
which is actually a system,
which interferes with the third agent so
to speak which is the Player,
the person that's controlling
what's going on in this world.
So, in this Pac-Man example the Author
would be the person
that created Pac-Man.
The Player would be
the person controlling Pac-Man running
around in this world and eating.
And then the Agent would be
the actual Pac-Man game itself, and
that Agent might have the ability
to change the way the ghost behave.
To set up another level that
has different properties or
whatever it wants.
And the goal of the Agent is
to create an experience for
the player that is consistent with
whatever it is the Author wants.
Does that make any sense at all?
>> At a high level.
I mean, how does the Author
express what he or she wants?
>> That's a good point.
So, he Author wants to
the Agent something,
the Player is going to be
interacting with the Agent and
the Author never gets to
play with the Player.
How does the Author express
to the Agent what it wants?
Well, that's what I'm
going to talk about but
let me just kind of give
you a little preview.
Imagine that the Author
says to the Agent.
I want the Player to be able
to win every level, but
only after they died several
times in that level.
I want the Player to feel like they
have to learn how to play better.
So the game has to be hard,
but it can be so
hard that the Player can never win.
>> Okay.
>> Now I haven't told you how to
communicate that with numbers, but
you can imagine that that's
an objective function.
It's a thing I could write
down that I keep track of
how quickly a Player
can go through a level.
Whether it gets better over time.
I could come up with a function that
tries to capture elements of that
either directly through
the experience or
by describing properties of the game,
properties of the Pac-Man level
that need to be traded off one another
in terms of things like difficulty.
>> Good.
>> So there's lots of ways of
doing it and people have been solving,
worrying about this problem for many,
many years now.
And I want to describe a particular
mechanism that combines this notion of
demonstrations and rewards so
that you can come up with a way for
this Author to convey
information to the Agent so
that the Player has an experience that
is consistent with the Author's intent.
Okay?
>> Neat yeah, that seems to fit with
a couple of things we've been talking
about in this lesson.
>> Excellent, so let's dive in.